no no I let all them down so what he
says in play walk now
because when my rushes did the wrong
things and a couple plays and just need
to be more of an impact player Nick Bosa
fitting himself for a pair of goat horns
potentially as we look at the goats in a
bad way draft for week 15 Chris we're
gonna pick three three guys each or I
guess guys coaches teams you can pick
the entire organization if you want
because nothing stopped you from doing
it in the past but before we get to it
we have to determine the first pick and
to do that trivia question time what do
you have for him all right drew brees
now has the record with 541 career TD
passes which player has caught more drew
brees TD passes than anyone else gosh
Marcus Colston how about that he was
there last night for he was there
anniversary the Super Bowl 44 team all
right I'm gonna jump right into it and I
am gonna go with it I yeah III feel like
I picked this guy every week but you
know what don't play like crap and you
won't be on the list Derek Carr I gotta
give it to Derek Carr he's the
quarterback of the team that lost the
last game that ever will be played at
the Oakland Coliseum how do you do that
how does that happen how does it how
what the jack the Jaguars had not logg
had not won a game excuse me on the west
coast since 2005 14 years went by and
they win that one and Derek Carr gets
booted off the field and I just look I
just feel like it's over for him in
Oakland from 6 and 4 to 6 and 8 and I
think Jon Gruden has been plotting
quietly for two years the upgrade to
another quarterback a better quarterback
than Derek Carr I don't know who it's
gonna be a lot of veterans are gonna be
available and we know he likes veterans
we know he wants another Rich Gannon and
I just think that that he's decided
Derek Carr is not the answer Chris well
I think it's 50/50 I'm with you there
know what's gonna happen but yeah you
know I dunno Jon Gruden and of course
he's not a big root should I pick Gruden
instead of car somebody on that team
this is what I mean it's disappointing
and I was with you there but this is
your missing and this is my first pick
you're missing the the biggest goat from
this game the freaking referees there a
card and we're not having this
conversation he slid in bounds the clock
shouldn't have stopped they stopped the
clock they screwed over the Oakland
Raiders that would have gave the Jaguars
significantly less time to have the ball
to score the referees and out river on
called John Gurdon to apologize but
Derek Carr who's sliding late in the
fourth quarter and we all know because
it happens every game that the
quarterback is marked down where he
starts his slide
he started his slide four yards from the
sideline and barely got to the sideline
at the end of the slide and they said he
went out of bounds that was a bonehead
mistake and the referees do we have that
play I would like to see that no I yeah
I mean that design was a disappointing
moment here's what I'm gonna say here's
what I'm gonna say don't don't go too
close I I don't why slide there why
leave any doubt just fall down there was
no one close to him right he wasn't
gonna get hit he wasn't sliding to avoid
contact yeah I think the message and the
and the learning the teaching the
coaching point for every other player
when you are at the sideline and you
want to stop the clock
don't risk sliding out of bounds never
go out of bounds fall down in batter it
is period don't risk it okay here he is
right there yeah I mean he did slide
yeah that was a slide yeah there's no
excuse like I understand what you're
saying he forward it a little bit but
like we can blame to her car but like
hey referees know the freakin rules I
mean that's all I can really say there
that's what said and again I feel bad I
feel bad right he's already blocked me
on Twitter so it's not like he can block
me again I feel that bad week in the
draft though but somebody somebody's
responsible and that part of his to
I'm I'm a little ticked off because the
Raiders covering was one of my best bets
before they can cover they have to win
yeah and how do they not with the
Jaguars got B forty five to ten by the
Chargers last week for crying out loud
and look the quarterback gets the credit
when things go well the quarterback gets
the blame when things go poorly so it
was grew nervous car and I'm going with
car because Gruden will be there next
year when they moved to Las Vegas car
won't well I hear you but you know I
checked the rule book to the defense is
allowed to stop a team when they have a
13-point lead and not let them come back
and win either so what rule is that is
that rule ten tackle by other team
before they reach your end zone go ahead
and sounds like something Moses brought
down from football go ahead what do you
got it's your pick I just picked oh you
picked it oh yeah I'm going Philip
Rivers because Philip Rivers had three
interceptions in what will be one of his
final games with the Chargers and again
if Derek Carr is responsible for what
happened in Oakland Philip Rivers is
responsible for what happened in LA
seven turnovers for the charters on
Sunday it should have been worse than
thirty nine to ten and they could have
won that game so look for every good
game Rivers has now it feels like he has
three or four or more bad ones I like
the guy he's been a great quarterback
it's over with the Chargers the question
is will he end up somewhere else you
think Jon Gruden would want Philip
Rivers uh he wouldn't want Philip Rivers
would he I don't think so I mean I think
Jon's got to be thinking future got a
building around somebody like that he
doesn't want to deal with the guy at the
end of his career I can't I can't
imagine that being the case but I'm with
you I mean Philip Rivers was on my list
too i was gonna kind of lump him and
melvin gordon together i mean for the
way they they put the the Chargers in
the hole to start the game into the
start of the third quarter it was it was
that game was there to be had you know
again it was there to be had and they'd
truly just in the ultimate chargers way
found a way to screw that screw that
whole thing up
so I'm with you that's a good pick all
the way there you know I think I got to
go with Devlin duck Hodges probably is
my next one as far as goat and you know
I know he throws four interceptions you
know I could sit there and say you know
two of them were not that bad I mean the
one at the end of the game
got to be desperate he threw another one
on a fourth down threw another one on a
third and long and ended up being a pun
but specifically the one he threw in the
third quarter today vyas white on the
right sideline across the field the
Steelers are up 10 to 7 and controlling
the football game and throws the ball
three or four feet behind the wide
receiver but just a moment of the game
where you know you just don't take that
chance there you don't you know there
you're controlling you got a you know a
superstar defense don't mess it up
three-point lead and you're in field
goal range to make a six point lead is
like huge with the kind of defense of
Pittsburgh Steelers have so Devlin
Hodges is he was the duck in a bad way
this week yeah and look those four picks
that matches what Mason Rudolph did in
the game before Rudolph was benched for
Hodges and now Mike Tomlin thinking
about what he's gonna do a quarterback
he may have an announcement later today
he does that Tuesday noon Eastern press
conference he may tell us who the
quarterback will be for the Pittsburgh
Steelers as they take on the Jets in New
Jersey this weekend I gotta go with Todd
Gurley as my final pick Todd Gurley had
a bad bad day at a time when it felt
like everything was moving in the right
direction for the Rams that offense
flows through him he's the straw that
stirs their drink he had and and if
you're an elite running back and if
you're gonna have a chip on your
shoulder when he was he was salty when
Jared Goff pointed out that Todd Gurley
had a vintage performance right in their
win against Seattle he didn't like that
I'm telling you what they got a tiptoe
on eggshells around Todd Gurley you got
to be careful what you say about him you
can't talk about his knee very sensitive
guy and if you're gonna be that way if
you're gonna view yourself as great
running back you got to deliver in big
spots season kind of on the line Todd
Gurley didn't get it done more pressure
on him and the Rams offense on Saturday
night against the 49ers but that offense
goes through Gurley and when that
offense gets shut down it's on Gurley
he's the goat number three for me for
week 15
yeah well I'm with you there you could
have probably picked a few people from
the Rams I mean it wasn't good I
obviously I might have gotten Jared God
there - I mean Jared Goff missed some
throws in the game again where you just
you know you making thirty three point
five or thirty four million dollars you
you can't do it but that was a pitiful
performance by the Rams across the board
it really was and you're right Gurley
wasn't great offensive line got whooped
Gothamist throws defense got whooped and
couldn't get off the field so there was
a lot of issues you think girlies on the
Rams next year no I don't I don't not
for the price tag what he's gonna make
next year a little over like around
eleven million dollars right close to
that if I remember correctly he's got
ten and a half million that becomes
fully guaranteed in march yeah and I
think before that happens the only thing
that I think would save him is if his
agent is permitted to see what someone
else is out here if he were available
right and he realizes there's nothing
and he maybe takes less to stay with the
Rams 2020 salary is a five point five
million dollar base salary and a 7.5
million dollar roster bonus paid next
year it fully guarantees I'll wait you
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute now hit boy they
did a nice job here they did a nice job
with this contract he's already got
money fully guaranteed for 2020 it's
money in 2021 that becomes fully
guaranteed right on on the third day of
the 2020 League year yeah they've got
some motion for one more year but
they're not gonna so they might have to
get rid of him to just stay out of the
financial liabilities of the 2021 season
yeah I got a look at this a little more
carefully but I think they got a problem
yeah they got a problem alright so
alright Jacque I just want to finish
this off of this but whooping I'm a
draft that I'm giving you here I'm going
with the Chicago Bears Jasper horse dead
okay
the rookie who didn't pitch the ball at
the end of the game that's how I got to
go with it I mean he robbed us all of a
great moment in football this year it
was the Stanford band moment it was oh
my gosh they're gonna score this is
unbelievable now I understand they had
to go for a two-point conversion to tie
the game anyways but this played out
perfectly tarik cone does a good job
back to chor Biscay
oh sure Biscay makes a move doesn't
panic does a good job getting extra
yards
makes the proper pitch open up your eyes
mr. man from Princeton you're from the
Ivy League look to the right and Alan
Robinson walks in here obtuse so he
becomes one of the goats of the week
sorry so it's not about anything it did
to the team it's about the fact that it
robbed us of a moment that we all would
have enjoyed very screw the team okay it
robbed us I wanted a great moment right
there they messed up for us so the
viewers I I can get behind that because
it looked like it was gonna happen yeah
it was one of those oh crap oh crap oh
crap they're gonna do this and and if he
just gets rid of it and realized he's
got a guy they're wide open then it
would have happened alright we're gonna
take a break one returned [ __ ] drew
brees historic night before we go though
my picks for today's goats in a bad way
draft Derek Carr Philip Rivers Todd
Gurley Simms has the Jacksonville and
officials duck Hodges and Jesper Porsche
step
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports